as many states begin to reopen we've
asked people from across the country to
record daily video diaries to share
their experiences
Jackie Wright and Nikki Howard our
Maryland sisters who started the
furlough cheesecake company after the
government shutdown of 2018 rancis perez
is founder of the Vita project a mindset
and fitness program based in New Jersey
Lindsey Nash owns a hair salon in
Georgia which is now open for business
and Bill wood is a California truck
driver who's been delivering food up and
down the west coast here now are their
personal accounts of life during the
pandemic
[Music]
no one's getting up everyone
swing
a little ghetto with his ass my computer
and that was over here
it says quarantine school time now
they're learning to cook breakfast there
would be many more being packaged being
with Kofi and the lack of events and the
uncertainty that's out there as many
it's getting more difficult from the
scope of nineteen that everybody's
paranoid and the showers are closed down
for us now there's hardly any
restaurants or anything foods get harder
to get so after over 30 days of
quarantine starting to get to me this
week's been around a bit rough for me a
big aspect of what I do is work with
people one on one and connect people
with people and haven't been able to
really do that so today we spent the
night cleaning the salon getting it
ready for tomorrow we're excited to go
back to work I bet so many people say
why don't you just get another job
there's no unemployment most of us
haven't seen our stimulus check you know
when you're not working for a month two
months it's a problem and not knowing
when this is all gonna go away just to
say we can't work for who knows how long
is scary I love my mom who came to live
with me right after the tooth kick was
born literally we're in covent 19 we do
not enter me our household so I'm not
allowed to be in my we're down here in
Long Beach getting ready to unload this
42,000 pounds of potatoes to a food bank
here in Long Beach we're bringing it in
the little trucks are taking it out we
were blessed to be able to make stew we
were able to do that and to bless the
homeless in our Cammie there's always
somebody out there who you can help
today was
not better date so I'm like I got a lot
of work done there's quite a few things
there rich had a good song meeting with
my partner did my workout today as
always you know push yourself to to do
the workout when you don't want to do
and those are the days that you feel the
best afterwards another great perk of
living here in Georgia and Springs is
Kona ice shows up
they've been making house calls and
school's out
still no food for us no nothing we're
back in here and Watsonville California
is your brakes going out today spending
some time outside with the kids looking
at me to claim that revitalize me I'm
back home fire if you're not getting out
get out they say be safe yeah make smart
and wise decisions and don't give up
don't give up keep dreaming keep dream
and work your dream
that's it work your dream so our new
normal I love these pieces and we do
them you know it seems like people are
working out their thoughts and their
feelings right on camera live with us
like we do with everyone at home every
morning and I appreciated that there was
some stress there people you know their
internal izing a lot of things and it
was coming out when they look into that
camera but also those moments of bliss
getting outside flying the kite doing a
little dance Gail I think we can all
relate to that as well listen I tell you
this Tony you always feel better when
you do the electric slide I've trampled
little children at our wedding to get to
the dance floor because you can do it by
yourself and everybody doesn't you're by
yourself but you also do it together but
I like what the sister said work your
dream Anthony I'll never forget that
they're working hard and working out
it's tough it's tough yeah yeah it is
food was an interesting theme in that
for everybody first of all I loved the
chicken soup that those two ladies were
making and then the ice cream truck
because an ice cream truck showed up
down the street for me here for the
first time in weeks I haven't felt that
excited to see an ice cream truck in
years